c'est décidé aéroports de paris va
renforcer la piste la plus longue d'orly
l'objectif permettre aux plus gros
biréacteur du monde de boeing 777 300er
de pouvoir décoller et se poser
également dans cet aéroport
c'est en effet à cet appareil qui va
bientôt être affecté aux vols en
direction des antilles et de la réunion
explications de patrick et stéroïdes et
pas nominaux le boeing 777 300er et le
dernier né de l'avionneur américain
air france a réceptionné son premier
exemplaire en avril 2004 au total la
compagnie en a commandé 12
c'est le plus gros bimoteur du monde
jusqu'ici ces avions sont utilisés sur
les vols long courriers comme paris
tokyo et décolle de l'aéroport de roissy
charles de gaulle mais les quatre
derniers 777 commandés viendront
rejoindre la flotte à partir de mai 2006
pour desservir la réunion et les
antilles ces vols sont réglementairement
opéré depuis orly seulement voilà les
pistes d'orly risque fort de ne pas être
à la hauteur
un réexamen des documents techniques
d'aéroports de paris vient juste de
révéler que l'état des chaussées
nécessita renforcement pour cet usage
intensif les boeing 747 décolle déjà
d'orly ils sont beaucoup plus lourds que
le 777 mais leur train d'atterrissage
compte presque deux fois plus de roue du
coup au décollage à pleine charge
la pression exercée sur chacune des
roues du 777 est considérable alors pour
faire face à la venue de nouveaux
monstres orly devra impérativement
renforcer sa piste la plus longue
ce qui d'ailleurs sera également utile
prochainement pour accueillir le futur
gros airbus 380